despite everything at risk leading up to
the premiere all of these Hollywood
execs were still willing to give Bert
Kreischer total creative control so you
can get your tickets that's very cool
man I'm excited for it I really want I
haven't seen it I think you'll I think
you'll like it I think you'll be
distracted because you're gonna go yeah
the one thing that anyone has seen it
says is can't believe you can act that
like that's everyone says that we've
been witnessing this new age of comedian
empowerment for a few years now with
more comics than ever producing their
own shows movies and specials which so
far seemed to work out pretty great for
Comedians and at the same time has kind
of hurt traditional media so it is
pretty rare to see a comedian leading
the production and getting their way on
a movie of this size of magnitude that
costs 35 million dollars and features
[__] Luke Skywalker